So Oscar,
you asked the question,
what are some of the easiest ways that
you can prove that the earth is round?
Because apparently this is something
that we're debating.
I have no idea why.
That's a hard thing for me to even start
talking about because there are so many
proofs that the earth is round.
It's difficult to know where to start
and it's not okay to think that the
earth is flat.
This is not a viable argument.
Um,
I have friends who have been on the
international space station.
They have orbited the earth once every
90 minutes.
You know,
I have had personal experience with
people that have been up in space and
can see with their own eyes that the
earth is round.
And of course we've taken all of these
amazing pictures from space that they're
so beautiful,
all those pictures of the earth.
So I don't really know what's going on
right now with this earth is flat thing.
But I will tell you that this is one of
the things I really enjoyed teaching my
own astronomy class about because there
are proofs all around you.
It is not difficult to know that the
earth is round.
In fact,
people have known this for way more than
2000 years.
The ancient Greeks actually had a number
of really elegant,
wonderful proofs that the earth was a
sphere.
So let's start from the simple to the
slightly more complicated.
One of the things you can see yourself
with a pair of binoculars is if you
actually go out to a lake and there are
boats on that lake.
The farther way of boat is,
the more the bottom of the boat will
disappear and you'll basically just see
the master of the boat and as a boat
goes farther and farther away,
the last thing you will see is the very
top of the master of that boat.
And that's because the boat is actually
going over the horizon that's curved.
And that means that as it goes farther
and farther away,
you see less and less of the bottom of
it and more of the top of that.
You can see that with binoculars,
by an ocean,
by lake,
it's really easy.
That wouldn't happen if the earth were
flat.
You would simply see the boat getting
smaller and smaller and smaller as it
went farther away,
but you'd be able to see the whole thing
with the same proportions.
Now another way that you can tell that
we're on a sphere is to think about how
there's something called the tropics on
the earth and the tropics are replaces
near the equator of the earth where
sometimes the sun is overhead in the
sky.
And this was actually something that the
Greeks used,
not only to prove that the earth was
round about 2000 years ago,
but they actually measured the
circumference of the earth accurate to
within just a couple of percent.
2000 years ago,
we've known that the earth was round.
There was a really brilliant Greek
scientists called Air Stoss,
denise and Aristotle,
and he's noticed that there was a town
called [inaudible],
and on a certain date,
the sun would actually shine straight
down to the bottom of a well.
That meant the sun was directly
overhead.
You could look down a well and see the
sun shining back at you and on the very
same date,
farther away in the city of Alexandria,
that didn't happen.
The son was not directly overhead,
it was a slight angle and all the air
stoss and he's did was he measured the
difference in the angle of the sun.
It was straight overhead and sign in
Alexandria,
it was a little bit less than overhead
and he rationed that that change in
angle from one city to another was
probably indicative of us being on a
curved surface.
And you could make all kinds of
measurements even between those two
cities and see that the angles were
different.
The Sun was at a different place in the
sky using this.
He actually measured the circumference
of the earth and he got it right 2000
years ago.
So another really simple proof is that
on any given date at different cities
and different places around the world,
the sun is at different angles in the
sky.
That wouldn't happen if the earth wasn't
around.
Then there's some other proofs that are
a little more obscure,
but they're actually really lovely and
one is to observe what happens during a
lunar eclipse.
Now a lunar eclipse happens when the
Earth casts a shadow on the moon.
The moon actually goes dark.
In fact,
if you've seen one,
you could actually see the earth's
shadow go across the moon and when the
moon is entirely in the Earth Shadow,
the moon looks kind of dark and even
kind of red colored.
It's really,
really beautiful.
What's happening in that case is that
the sun is on one side of the earth are
this in the middle and it's casting.
A shadow of the earth is casting a
shadow on the moon and as the shadow
moves across the moon,
you'll notice that the shadow is curved.
It's round.
So something like the sun that's bigger
than the earth and is able to cast a
shadow of the earth on the moon can
actually show you the shape of the
earth.
A high,
you might say,
but could the earth be a disc?
Could it be flat?
But it's actually still shaped like a
disc,
not like a sphere.
There was a Greek scientists called air
starkist and what he noticed was that
you can get a lunar eclipse at many
different angles where the sun is.
Sometimes the shadow goes straight
across the moon.
Sometimes it just kind of glances the
moon just a little bit as in shadow,
just on the top or on the bottom from
every different vantage point,
every different angle of the sun is
casting a shadow.
You always get a perfectly curved
shadow.
The only shape that can cast a shadow
that's curved from any direction you put
the light is a sphere.
So people have known that the earth is
spherical for thousands of years.
It's not okay to say that the earth is
flat.
This is some sort of strange denial.
I don't know where it comes from and
it's something where I keep getting this
question.
We really need to put this question to
bed because we've known the earth as a
sphere for a long time.
They there,
there's some even well meaning people
that have kind of,
you know,
they say,
well,
I don't really believe the earth is
flat,
but I'm not really sure what to think
about it.
And they've asked me some interesting
questions like,
um,
you know,
they've heard that the,
uh,
that space is very hot.
You know,
that when you,
when you go up above the atmosphere,
the temperature spaces millions of
degrees,
which is true.
Uh,
the,
the problem is there's basically no air
at all.
So I mean,
I mean the,
the gas right around the earth is
actually millions of degrees hot.
That's actually true.
But there's almost no,
none of it.
There's almost nothing like one single
Proton whizzes by you at a temperature
of a million degrees.
It's not the same as temperature like
in,
in the air.
It's not the same thing at all.
So that one was a one that I get some
times.
And the other one is,
I'm actually said this to somebody I
couldn't believe they'd never thought of
it.
That,
you know,
with binoculars,
you can see planets,
you can see Saturn and Jupiter.
You can,
as you can see,
Mars with a telescope,
the sun,
the moon,
everything else you see in solar system
is a sphere.
So we're,
we're the one thing that is different,
you know?
And,
and that actually,
that actually made somebody who was,
it was more interested in actually
hearing information that she got them to
think.
They're like,
you're right.
You know,
you know,
everything else we take a picture of as
a sphere.
Hmm.
Yeah.